وفي ايران مره اخرى وفي وصف للوضع الراهن
للشارع هناك كتبت صحيفه ليموند الفرنسيه
في تقرير لها ان الوضع اشبه بالهدوء الذي
يسبق العاصفه الصحيفه عللت وصفها هذا بان
الشعب غاضب وقريبا ستستانف حركته الاحتجاج
وبانضمام اكبر الى صفوف المتظاهرين نتيجه
الوضع الاقتصادي المتردي في البلاد ونقلت
الصحيفه عن مصادر ايرانيه ان الاحتجاجات
الحاليه لم تفشل ولم تنتهي وان المتظاهرين
يعيدون بناء قواتهم ويراجعون تجربتهم
الاحتجاجيه لادراك اخطائهم من اجل اعاده
تنظيم انفسهم تدهور الوضع الاقتصادي
للايراني خلال الاسابيع الماضيه اصبح احد
العوامل العوامل الغضب الشعبي والقلق
المستمر بشان المستقبل بحسب شهادات تحدثت
معها الصحيفه الفرنسيه